de la communauté internationale c'est le
cas ou pas presque d'autres pays
je sais je sais que le prénom de la
République Emmanuel Macron travaille
pour pour rallier d'autres États
européens à la cause je sais que
l'Allemagne a fait un pas supplémentaire
effectivement voilà il s'est un travail
important à mener parce qu'en fait
l'Europe et on a vu de quelle manière
lorsqu'une avant dernier la présidente
la Commission européenne se comporte
avec le président Aliette qu'elle
considère comme un partenaire exemplaire
et loyal
justement parce qu'il y a un contrat qui
a été signé entre l'Union européenne et
l'Azerbaïdjan sur la question du gaz
vous demandez que ce contrat soit rompu
on imagine je demande que l'Europe
retrouve ses esprits elle les a perdu
avec la fête
elle a perdu ses esprits et la part du
sa force l'Europe est cliente
elle paye pour avoir ce gaz et donc
c'est l'Europe qu'en position de force
par rapport à lazerbaïdjan pour vous
elle est pas dépendante du gaz elle est
en position de force mais demain on peut
trouver d'autres la France par exemple
n'achète pas de gaz à laserbaïdjan
la France a trouvé d'autres d'autres
partenaires pour pour le gaz aujourd'hui
comme l'Azerbaïdjan ne fournit pas ne
produit pas assez de gaz pour fuir
l'Europe vous savez ce qu'elle fait elle
achète du gaz à la Russie et c'est le
gaz russe qui est fournit en Europe mais
tout le monde le sait j'ai eu cette
conversation avec le président de la
République vous dites que c'est une
façon de détourner le blocus mais c'est
un c'est une rupture de l'embargo en
fait c'est une prise de la République
lui-même vous en a parlé tout le monde
est au courant en Europe tous les
dirigeants sont au courant en Europe et
aujourd'hui au lieu d'importer du gaz
russe via les abeilles hypocrisie
c'est-à-dire au lieu d'acheter que
l'Europe achète directement le gaz russe
à 100 elle achète le gaz russe via
l'Azerbaïdjan à 150 c'est à dire que
l'Europe enrichit et la Russie et
l'Azerbaïdjan et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'Europe a un moyen de
pression beaucoup plus fort que celui de
Bakou envers l'Europe en réalité
[Musique]